baik lagi laporan terkini
vlademir puting
menang besar dalam pilihan raya presiden Rusia
yang berlangsung 3 hari
berakhir semalam
ia berdasarkan keputusan hasil tinjauan pendapat awal
oleh badan pemerhati
Yayasan pusat kajian pendapat awam Rusia vcrum
antara lain keputusan awal itu mendedahkan puting
bekas prinsip kgb menang dengan mendapat 87.8% undi
manakala saingannya calon komunis
nikolai karitonov
menduduki tempat ke-2 dengan hampir 4% undi
radius life
davan coff pula di tempat ke-3 dan loanate soutski
ultra nasionalis di tempat ke-4
dengan masing masing memperoleh hanya 3.8
dan 3.0% undi
kemenangan puting dalam keputusan awal itu
adalah yang paling bergaya
pernah dicetakkan bagi pemimpin pasca Soviet
dengan kemenangan itu
bermakna puting dengan mudah menjamin 1
tempoh 6 tahun penggalian baharu
sekaligus membolehkannya mengatasi rekod jasastalin
selain
menjadi pemimpin Rusia yang paling lama berkhidmat
kemenangan itu
juga akan mengukuhkan lagi cengkaman kuasanya
di negara itu
beliau masih mencatatkan kemenangan
di sebalik ribuan pembangkang
mengadakan protes di stesen pengundian
pada waktu tengah hari
dan kritikan Amerika Syarikat
bahawa pengundian itu tidak bebas atau adil
bagi puting yang pertama kali naik kuasa pada 1999
keputusan adalah cerminan untuk menegaskan kepada barat
bahawa pemimpinnya perlu menghadapi Rusia
yang semakin berani
sama ada dalam peperangan atau dalam keamanan
untuk bertahun tahun akan datang
pilihan raya presiden Rusia diadakan
lebih 2 tahun selepas puting memulakan konflik Eropah
paling buruk sejak Perang Dunia Kedua
dengan melancarkan operasi ketenteraan khas di ukrain
perang yang berpanjangan
menggantung proses pilihan raya
di beberapa wilayah di ukrain